I think John Campea not really nice lady
Obama okay wedding hey guys this is Inka
some of you might know I was in Tokyo a
couple months back where I filmed a
bunch of videos out of our Japan office
and this is one of them I had a lot of
fun shooting this with red who didn't
understand a single thing I said but if
you enjoy watching videos like this you
guys should definitely check out Ria's
recipe exchange student videos which are
also a lot of fun all right enjoy
oh my god I feel like I feel like she's
yelling at me
hi my name is red I'm tasty Japan video
producer and today I'm going to cook
something with following the Cantonese
instruction like a ho oh hi Inca
BuzzFeed gecko video producer Camila oh
hi you Heidi don't kow red theme runs
and we go along here okay
ah lady ho yeah yeah yeah ha ha ha
okay yeah yeah you know how they come I
think yet so try it out there's the
coral ahora is a Korra
in Cantonese their hoard oh wow oh yeah
he's chicken guy yes yeah yeah chicken
wing oh okay so they come I ain't gonna
go recipes hey Daniel oh hi teeth at all
they go hey yes I saw Cena you go girl
this is that all the ingredients are
there you got you John baby
titi titi titi chop something I you one
yeah hi girl
okay good girl good girl
maybe
oh yeah I think I see you love I lamp in
low angle you cut hot
yep on a huge home you're not gonna cut
this so I'm gonna choose this oh this is
a like a first step okay
it's our hope our echo John for fun oh
oh like a high heat oh hi hey hi boy
whoa jump I say boy I like Paul Tonko I
fall type of me though middle hit okay
fire fire see you see was that okay yeah
a little bit okay hi I'm Shoni okay she
died what is today's a reason why you
put this because oh yeah mm-hmm
following up her bowel her okay good
this poor girl is good well they got
your journals girl falling up oh yeah
Wow oh oh you want the ticking half of
like a flavor of the ginger man Kyle
okay thank you
come on you gotta at the hygienic and
pull it up are you talking about
everything
hi-yah hi-yah hi-yah okay chicken so
scary you know crazy producers okay I
know yeah I'm a safety producer
vice-chair though there's no baby no
more Oh turns to the brown hi flip over
hi
okay but like is uh like a popular in
hold on
all gone I want to eat right now so I
like how they tear our crew aren't
60-man are talking about color so you
want me to what's up hey is a chicken
yeah yeah winger oh I'm learning
hey it looks good it smells good all
good
Oh yo holla oh my gosh see our I didn't
know that okay no I understand that
I don't know what saying I wanna
understand her but I can't so hey good
morning I do you want me to take out the
ginger okay she look fire follow
oh my CEO oh come on I got cieaura Oh
soy sauce oh my gosh even z7d up
okay cow yeah yeah say yeah yeah say
yeah say water
don't make me laugh look I didn't know
that you can use the coca-cola in to die
for
hi sequin fun hi oh don't be you fun and
stop the heat Oh medium
okay I a sweating so hard kisser I was
I'm so nervous
I think I'm doing great right almost
like say oh they're like a chicken they
can make a dumb video wait how do you
say recipe Oh Olaf
oh look I yeah oh oh my god I love it
oh okay hey y'all hold on come on you
gotta hedge oh you got and Danya hi it's
an easy recipe easy recipe I see
[Music]
well that until become like a thick
thick thick sauce it's like a teriyaki
okay okay go for a high sugar oh that's
why I've become like a sauce
oh my god papa
yeah they definitely gonna cook this
again because it's it's easy and it
looks good on me okay
[Music]
I think with that oh my god yeah yours
reminds me of like the ones that I used
to have going on I want to try yours
first yeah great
this is exactly like like it
this is like the bottom right oh my god
much better then you know the teriyaki
cuz it's so easy I know I'm gonna make
this one tonight I'm so impressed you
did so well
Thank You sensei thank you thank you
that was all you man that was all you
you guys saw how easy it is if Fred can
do it without really knowing full
instructions yeah I think you guys can
totally try so please try it at home and
let us know if you do I'd be so proud
thank you for watching this video please
leave like for watching bye
[Music]